[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
almighty God grant to us all needed
guidance wisdom and judgment
as we
face the tasks before us
and enable us now and always weirdily to
discharge the sacred Trust
placed by the people in our hands amen
um apologies now we've got one for
lately I've got an apology from
councilor Clark your worship
um he'll be late he's just getting a job
done and apologies for me because I'll
have to leave if I get a a telephone
call so if we can get a couple of
important telephone calls
oh you're gonna have her energy
politeness
I'll move
second
thank you
Declaration of Interest
any changes to that
and uh
public forum
anyone speaking to that
foreign
major like later items
[Music]
yes
Council as there are a number of major
late items today and the reason to that
is because of the timing of meetings
you'll see that we're looking for you to
receive the minutes of the PPP committee
meeting of last week both the public and
public excluded session obviously the PE
minutes will be taken in PE then from
the risk and Assurance committee meeting
just held this morning there are the
recommendations only in relation to the
unaudited draft annual report which we
would like you to receive and resolve in
public excluded and there is a
recommendation to council arising from
the meeting this morning that we'd like
you to consider they're all major items
and so far as we're asking you to pass a
resolution that relates to them and the
reason is that to allow you to deal with
them in this term a council please I'll
move that way you worship
moved second did you worship
and seconded any further discussion
put it to The Verge all in favor say aye
aye against carried
and we move on to the
minutes of the meeting of council out on
the 23rd of August
seeking the Jewish it's moved and
seconded any discussion questions
put it to the vote all in favor say
aye
against carried
minutes of the risk and or
risk and or Assurance committee
meeting out on the 25th of August
I'll move those who worship
moved in second any discussion
put it to devote all in favor say aye
aye against carried
foreign
community board meeting held on the 12th
of September 2022 I'll move those to
worship seeking them you worship
moved and seconded any discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say
aye aye against
foreign
minutes of the infrastructural services
committee held on the 13th of September
2022
yes you worship I would like to move
that we receive the minutes and also
adopt the recommendations and they are
the adoption of the parking control
bylaw
as in regards to 4th Street as
highlighted in the minutes and also
adopt the recommendation to Council of
the parking control by law for a Q Road
near Street as highlighted in the
minutes and also adopt the cemeteries
and crematorium bylaw as well as in the
minutes
second that you're worship
moved and seconded discussion questions
put it to the vote to all in favor say
aye aye
against Herod
moved a minutes of infrastructural
services committee
right meeting held on the 13th of
September
20. just on that you worship oh
recommendations to council
they're up on the screen
sorry
perhaps you could move oh there is one
um number 12 the road stopping and
Disposal have stopped right oh so sorry
there's one missed out there sorry
that's the recommendation for the road
stopping and disposal of stop Road Lagan
Street
I'd like to move that your ship
put it to the boat
oh sorry any discussion
if not I'll put it to the vote
all in favor say aye
aye aye against
carried
now these appendices
invercargill city council Holdings
Limited purchase the shares and roaring
electricity limited partnership
believe it
certainly um
was a
controversial issue
sorry guys
oh that's all right for you you know
like to encourage
okay
there's um quite a few issues where
acid stripping was a sort of No-No in
the three Waters debate
and a lot of the resolutions
uh that we will be dealing with
later on the agenda
do have a sort of
an undertone for those who opposed asset
stripping
um
it certainly is
an issue that
it may not be in the short term but in
the long term
could have ramifications
on a wide scale
electricity of course is
those who sat around this table for some
time
will know that
the um
shares and various electricity
companies of
always been a a especially that have
cancer so I had to wrestle with on many
occasions
thank you
now
and you're on the independence
Holden's purchase of shares and twister
Cameron's head ready to speak to his
report oh
Mr Cameron would you like to speak to
your report thank you worship
um this matter has come before Council
previously where there's some
consultation around this purchase this
paper seeks to remedy an era where we
neglected to pass the appropriate
recommendation that came up from the
committee in terms of accepting the
outcome of that consultation and
improving the ability to go ahead with
the purchase the second part is to as
shareholder uh plus resolution to enable
yourself is the mayor to sign an
authority for the company to undertake
what would be a major transaction for
the company and the third piece of
information that this paper updates is
the question around whether or not the
company would be uh considered to be a
council controlled organization
following the purchase and the advice
that we have from audit New Zealand is
that they were treated as such and we're
comfortable with that advice and happy
to progress with the purchase on that
basis
have you answer any questions
yes any of any other
comments the big guide
counselor logo thank you worship um
as Mr Cameron said we did go through the
uh the issue at PPP which is sent
through the recommendations to council
I'm happy to move the full resolutions
upon the uh
screen set
happy to Second those your worship can I
just suggest that resolution number one
uh needs written out in full
it thank you councilor Soper it will be
in full on your board books and malavika
will just make sure that it shows
correctly
any further issues councilors wish to
address
on electricity
that I can put it
you know
moved and seconded
put it to um
sorry counselor Ludlow what what's the
issue you were raising no issue sir I
was just moving the full recommendations
okay
there being no further discussion
so I'll put it to the boat
all in favor say aye aye aye against
carried
move on to
a dog and Animal Control update
is a result of the review it has been
necessary to re-escalate the Animal
Control fund
let's see the relationship here on item
11 the minutes of PPP oh on 20 September
so you worship I'm happy to move the
minutes received and
that the recommendations to council
under item seven for the dog and Animal
Control fund update
um
adopted
moved and seconded any discussion
questions
put it to the boat all in favor say aye
aye aye against carried
urgent business
uh sorry uh the later items there were a
little couple in public
so there's one in front of you
and we'll come back to that counselor
sorry
foreign
we'll come back to that
to what
to the mural report
uh no I wasn't going to mention that I
just really wanted to know
the software it's a personal statement
that's all
you worship I'm happy to move the
recommendation that's currently
on the screen
a little bit of second it
it's moved and seconded and resolved at
the recommendation to council arising
from the risk and Assurance committee
meeting uh held on the 27th of
September 2022 be confirmed
let's draw a mover and secondary for
that
uh
uh and councilor Edmondson has second
ever
okay
you know further discussion
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye against carried
and move on to
the Assurance committee meeting held on
the 27th of September
2022 be confirmed
and we've done that so move on to item
10.
oh yes
he's on screen
is cancer I have it he wished to make a
personal statement
yes I do
your commissions I wish to make a
personal statement and just remind
people that are not debatable which is a
personal statement
and I'll lead it off I'm scripted it so
I'm going to read it no apologies and I
start by saying
world of stage and all the men and women
merely players they have their exits and
their entrances and one man in his time
plays many parts
well I had an entrance in 1971 when I
was 22.
in those times the youngest elected
counselor in the history of New Zealand
that's changed of course
a break for many years while I explored
and fulfilled dreams Ambitions and love
and then a return in 2007.
takes me to 18 years in total
now as the quote from a Jacques Seven
Ages of Men says I take my exit I'm not
sure if it's stage left or stage right
so I never ever got that right but did I
dare him
um in Romeo and Juliet supporting a
sweet sorrow
um I'll abridge that and say I'm parting
is quite sweet
the covert epidemic had a huge effect on
me personally
and to be frank still does
I have impending further serious
operations that could be called at any
time
and a surgeons and medical experts have
suggested that categorically I stay safe
and my associations be limited
so with the utmost respect to them and
what they've done for me it goes without
a question that I need to play that part
too I did so as a matter of gratitude
and deepest heartfelt thanks my enormous
duration resulted in my non-attendance
physically in a personal capacity at
Council
but the technology of Zoom Etc still
allowed me to participate
I have however determined that it was
unfair of me to utilize the use of zoom
and deny a place around the council for
a candidate in the forthcoming elections
just to go back and reflect on my
Hospital
admissions for a minute I'd like to
thank Tim said well for his many visits
and to the bedside and as gifts and also
the genuine concerns and offer of
assistance from down Ludlow and
for Graham Lewis
our CEO also our CE also frequently
inquired about my welfare health and
offered Alternatives and suggestions to
abilities to attend and I think you've
about clear
another realization was that it's 73
years of age the will have moved on at
what seems to be in an alarming rate
and whilst I resisted many changes like
King Canute I cannot hold the flow with
Thai bag of Technology the new speak
with abbreviations the new Dynamics the
consistent technical London reports and
the Bloody rules
um I don't get to to start on that too
much but just that phrase again in the
good old days and they were good old
days and just to tell you that um we
took arguments to the public hallways
they were packed with both points of
view firmly
place
and what would now be termed as perhaps
disorderly would only raised voices
tables Bank cheers and booze but you
know what they were never any fisticuffs
or bad bad mouthing
and there was nothing physical and the
audience as they left would be
accompanying each other still perhaps
continuing their debate but with respect
I've said before in my opinion the bait
has been stifled
by the implementation of rules
regulations procedural methods and the
ever increasing threat of personal
grievances there have been many Petty I
call investigations and workshops
workshops
behaviorism and the team building
facilitated by out of town facilitators
the cost to this Council tens of
thousands of dollars
seriously I did not then and I never do
see the value of those
dollars and I don't see a lot of
Behavioral changes and I evidence that
without taking sides a prime example and
that is was the consistent marriage of
criticism fault finding and the faction
between the mayor councilors and CE I
will say no more about that subject and
the Public's perception will be
reflected in results of the present
ongoing election
in my moments of
reflection I recognize my lack of the
new skills the new skills base the ever
constant changing rules as I mentioned
and I came to the conclusion it was time
to move on and give others an
opportunity and I believe that others
are better
would in my opinion be wise to do the
same at 73 years of age I do not want to
become the epitome of a grumpy old man
Sans teeth Sans mind sends memory again
attributed to sharks
the Mages of men
I cannot and will not let this moment
pass without a reference to councilor
kit
two months prior to the nominations
a certain awakeness in public
quickly sought endorsement for his
accusations regarding three Waters he
was flying a kite to my opinion
councilor Super armiston Cracker Ludlow
Lush and myself were passionate
Advocates against
three Waters and were parties to strong
representation to the minister and the
continued advocacy on the rate payers
behalf all of those mentioned beforehand
all they did was to prefer the council's
choice of action rather than be a party
to a minority group which were not well
informed had a potential to become
hostile and had a considerable
membership of persons outside the
invercargill electorate
other representations in this
advertisement are at best colored and
not represent true outcome on facts and
that seems to be a motorcycle and I of
the individual
good luck to you all in the fourth
coming elections and may the best of you
win my ambition is to watch closely on
the sidelines make public comments and I
don't assume it they'll be negative
some will be of course my biggest and
most sincere if
thanks go to the electors of
invercargill who have over a period of
18 years supported me encouraged me
debated with me and assisted me it is
you the people that have been my
foremost consideration
that made the journey worthwhile so I
thank you people of invercargill enough
said just a quote from the great old
song called wandering the King's Highway
and the lyrics go like this I've never
been
Rover summer and winter too wandering
the white will over tricking my whole
life through but as I start my journey
and this was the new one at the end of
another day I give a health to comrades
and
owls of the Great Highway so comrades
farewell what if we never meet again the
memory will stay as I go rain or snow
wandering the King's Highway thank you
foreign
[Applause]
yeah
um the next item is the mayoral report
and
I've circulated them to all the
councilors
um
and it's come back now
foreign
s
that I've been involved in during this
election
period
but um
trying to keep
as neutral as possible
foreign
challenging and it is always a
challenging task balancing our
responsibilities to the voting
discharging of our election
electoral
position
this term has been no exception
and I would like to
foreign
that we have each other's
have each other learned
the importance of basic pillars
in our elected roles
and um
then it goes on to the discussion
about the Merrell robes
um
I think about
parties
um
have reached
agreement
um
because I don't feel I'm in a position
to
um
foreign
who have supported us over the last
three years
often brought
it can be
but
we've got through the work
in terms of the inner city upgrade
and
infrastructure
pressures on our rating system and
water
in particular
I was yesterday attended the Queen's
honor
um
foreign
service
and I was amazed to hear that one of the
premieres
said he um
the
uh had voted from the last three
elections and stood for office
and he wasn't a New Zealand citizen
so it seems people can still slip
through
they are not careful though
check up on their
positions
on the one hand of course it should be
left to the next
incoming Council
but um
I feel that
there's also an argument a legitimate
argument
suggesting that
um
foreign
engage in her wide range of activities
beside the traditional salute to the
queen
um
I found it in
encouraging and
incredibly
um
encouraging
and
that
no tahu and Council
meets to try and plant a million
trees
and uh
it was certainly inspirational
seeing such a large-scale project
involving
many sectors of the community
so I'll move my report be
received
and thank you for your service over the
years
thank you
any further comments discussion
go to the vote all in favor say aye aye
against
carried
and I think it's got it on the screen
here
reasons
what are you suggesting Claire
always
where's the item here
oh
you're worship I'm happy to move that we
um move into public excluded for the
reasons outlined here on the screen so
the confirmation of the minutes of the
public excluded session of council held
on 23rd of August public exclusive
excluded session of risk and Assurance
on 25th of August that we've received
some minutes of infrastructural services
Committee in PE for the 13th
and and like I will Central Holdings
Limited director appointments
the receiving of the minutes of the
public excluded exception of PPP for on
the 20th of September and the 2022 draft
annual report an audited version I'll
second that your worship
moved and seconded
any discussion on that
foreign
to support democracy in action
it's uh
it's not an easy
prior to travel but
it's it's an important one when you see
the variety of work that's involved
all in favor say aye carried